tag 4 der haushaltsberatung zum
bundeshaushalt
2022 und in der tat das ist der
abschluss einer parlamentarischen woche
die nicht wie üblich bei
haushaltsberatungen also wieso lange und
anstrengend auch für die abgeordneten
ist sondern es ist keine gewöhnliche
haushaltsberatung hier gewesen das haben
auch abgeordnete während der debatten
immer wieder betont denn es ist der
erste bundeshaushalt den die ampel
verantwortet aber vor allem standen und
stehen diese haushaltsberatung unter dem
eindruck des angriffskriegs von russland
gegen die ukraine und auch der dortigen
humanitären lage und auch der
bundeshaushalt der etat ist und wird
beeinflusst vom krieg in der ukraine das
hat christian lindner der
bundesfinanzminister deutlich gemacht
und bereits einen ergänzungs haushalt
angekündigt darin wird unter anderem
beispielsweise weitere hilfen für die
ukraine berücksichtigung finden aber
auch entlastungen für die bürgerinnen
und bürger heute bevor dann am
nachmittag das ganze haushaltsgesetz der
entwurf mit allen einzelplänen in die
weiteren beratung in die ausschüsse
überwiesen wird gibt's nochmal die
schlussrunde hier am mittag mit
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
und davor der etat des
familienministeriums steht hier auf der
tagesordnung und der große etat arbeit
und soziales 160 milliarden diese zahl
kann man ruhig noch mal nennen ausgaben
sind allein in diesem jahr geplant mehr
als ein drittel des gesamten
bundeshaushalts und da ist es doch gut
dass wir heute morgen zum interview
bevor es drinnen im plenarsaal losgeht
zwei abgeordnete bei uns haben die sich
mit arbeitsmarkt und sozialem bestens
auskennen ich darf einmal begrüßen zu
seine fesche für die linke die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
und martin rosemann für die spd-fraktion
der sprecher für arbeit und soziales
terrors man vierter tag der
haushaltsberatung jetzt haben wir diese
woche in der generaldebatte auch in der
allgemeinen finanzdebatte schon viel
gehört über schwerpunkte der ampel
klimaschutz energiesicherheit natürlich
die ukraine hilfe spielte eine rolle
aber auch die verteidigungsfähigkeit der
bundeswehr sozialpolitik spielte noch
nicht so eine rolle jetzt haben wir
heute die lesung aber trotzdem fällt auf
dass zentrale sozialpolitische vorhaben
gerade auch der spd nicht in der
budgetplanung vorkommen und auch nicht
in der mittelfristigen finanzplanung
beispielsweise nichts über das
bürgergeld und nichts über die
kindergrundsicherung warum
ein bürgergeld und kindergrundsicherung
erst ab dem jahr 2023
relevant werden da gibt es noch keine
gesetze und wenn es keine gesetze gibt
dann ist das auch noch nicht reif und
befindet sich das im haushalt 2022 noch
nicht wieder es ist aber so dass wir ja
in der besonderen situation sind das wir
weil wir als ampel erst ende letzten
jahres ins amt gekommen sind wir sind ja
für 2022
in der vorläufigen haushaltsführung wir
machen jetzt in haushalts 22 aber im
bundeskabinett wird bereits im juni der
haushalt für 2023 dann beraten und da
werden sich diese projekte
selbstverständlich wieder finden ich war
deswegen nicht nur haushalt herisch
sondern tatsächlich alles fällt auf weil
diese projekte die ja sehr zentral sind
auch für die spd fraktion noch nicht
angeschoben sind und das sind ja sehr
langfristige projekte der sozialverband
deutschland er hat schon mal angesichts
dieser haushaltsberatung gewarnt dass
die ampel nicht beispielsweise ukraine
hilfe finanziell auflegt zu lasten der
sozialpolitik wie wollen sie diesen
eindruck entgegentreten es in der tat so
dass in einer krise die wir jetzt haben
dass da immer es darum geht sicherheit
zu garantieren und 23 hinsicht äußere
sicherheit innere sicherheit und
sozialer sicherheit gerade in der krise
geht es jetzt darum den sozialen
zusammenhalt zu sichern und zu
stabilisieren und das ist ja auch einer
der gründe warum wir jetzt bereits zwei
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
haben mit dem wir gerade dafür sorgen
dass die gesellschaft jetzt zusammenhält
und besonders diejenigen entlasten die
besonders von den hohen energiepreisen
betroffen sind die arbeitende mitte und
menschen am unteren rand der
einkommensskala
auf das entlastungspaket was gestern das
zweite was gestern gerade vorgestellt
jetzt kommen wir gleich noch mal was da
die soziale entlastung angeht fesche von
ihrer fraktion hat man in dieser
haushaltswoche dutzendfach schon gehört
dass dieser haushalt ein
sozialpolitisches streichkonzert sei
jetzt haben wir wird der etat 160
milliarden der soll wachsen bis 2026 auf
180 milliarden wo fehlt ihnen denn geld
für arbeit und soziales jetzt meine muss
man ja sehen dass der etat auch
rückläufig ist und zum anderen ist es so
dass wesentliche forderungen oder dinge
die wirklich die menschen mit niedrigen
einkommen entlasten würden sie uns
angesprochen bürgergeld oder eine
mindestrente wir haben die zunehmende
altersarmut dass sie überhaupt nicht im
haushalt abgebildet sind diese ganzen
forderungen also immens bürgergeld
mindestrente und eine erhöhung des
rentenniveaus nehmen würde wären wir
ungefähr bei 30 milliarden euro das ist
nicht da das geld angeblich aber auf der
anderen seite gibt man über nacht stellt
man sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
euro für ausrüstung zur verfügung und
wir sagen es muss was zum sozialen
zusammenhalt getan werden weil der
innere frieden natürlich auch elementar
ist und immerhin es ist ja angesprochen
worden mit den steigenden energiepreisen
die korona krise es waren insgesamt
insbesondere die niedrigen und die
mittleren einkommen die entsprechend
massiv belastet worden sind und dem
entlastungspaket kommen die rentnerinnen
bin ich opa studierende wären überhaupt
nicht berücksichtigt
heraus man darf ich ganz kurz noch
fragen zwischendurch weil wir wollen
dass auch für die zuschauer etwas
transparenter noch machen tatsächlich
vollmers mal konkret machen an diesem
entlastungspaket 2 was gestern die ampel
vorgestellt hat da ist unter anderem
darin dass jeder erwerbstätige einmal
eine einmalzahlung von 300 euro bekommen
soll für jedes kind gibt der staat
einmalig 100 euro empfänger von
sozialleistungen erhalten
einmalzahlungen von 200 euro statt 100
euro
das hört sich ein bisschen so an es ist
für alle was dabei und sozial gestaffelt
ist doch da eigentlich nicht warum hat
man alle entlastet und nicht gezielt
kleinere und sozial schwache das stimmt
ja so nicht also wir fokussieren auf
diejenigen die besonders betroffen sind
von den hohen energiepreisen und sie
müssen beide entlastungspaket das
entlastungspaket 1 das ja sogar vor
beginn das ukraine kriegs schon auf den
weg gebracht wurde und das
entlastungspaket zwei jetzt gestern
zusammen betrachten und dann haben wir
zwei maßnahmen die sich besonders an
leute mit geringem 1 richten das eine
ist die einmalzahlung diese schon
angesprochen haben ursprünglich waren
100 euro verabredet jetzt hat man
verabredet dass weitere 100 euro dazu
kommen und das zweite ist der
heizkostenzuschuss für bezieherinnen
bezieher von wohngeld und unter anderem
übrigens auch vom bafög und deswegen
stimmt es nicht dass studierende nicht
berücksichtigt sind und diesen
heizkostenzuschuss den haben wir hier
schon ins gesetz gegossen und der hat
sich im parlamentarischen verfahren ja
noch mal verdoppelt das heißt wir
konzentrieren uns sehr wohl auf
geringverdiener und bei diesem 300 euro
und auch bei den 100 euro für jedes kind
ist es ja so dass das dann bei der
einkommensteuer entsprechend verrechnet
werden das heißt gutverdiener bekommen
unterm strich weniger menschen mit
geringerem einkommen bekommen unter dem
strich mehr auf hersteller herr rose man
sagt doch sozial schwache und auch
kleinere einkommen profitieren und in
der tat zumindest könnten diese
maßnahmen ja sehr schnell und
unbürokratisch rücken oder es ist ja
auch nicht so dass wir sagen es ist
komplett in die falsche richtung gedacht
aber es ist halt schon sowie hosen man
gesagt hat dass die 300 euro jeder
bekommt und natürlich wird über die
steuer entsprechend auch wieder
besteuert trotzdem ist es doch
eigentlich nur sinn wenn zum beispiel
jemand wie ich als bundestagsabgeordnete
auch davon profitiert also ich finde ab
einem bestimmten einkommen ist es
definitiv nicht nötig und das geld fehlt
natürlich bei den menschen die es
dringend nötig haben also selbst wenn
man jetzt bei den hartz iv
empfängerinnen wissen ja auch menschen
die zu niedrige löhne haben die
aufstocken rentnerinnen und rentner die
in der grundsicherung sind mit 200 euro
da ist es doch nicht getan also die sind
doch jetzt in der pandemie schon seit
zwei jahren über die maßen belastet und
biss ist auch der vorwurf den ich mach
das wäre problemlos möglich gewesen
zumindestens das bürgergeld
kindergrundsicherung verstehe ich noch
das ist relativ komplex aber das
bürgergeld entsprechend zu erhöhen so
dass diese menschen dauerhaft wirklich
in würde leben können und dafür sind
mindestens 600 euro im monat möglich das
sagen im übrigen auch alle sozial
verbringen weil sie immer vergessen frau
ferschl ist das wenn sie den regelsatz
zu erhöhen gibt es natürlich argumente
dafür dass die dann gleichzeitig das
steuerliche existenzminimum
dann profitiert dann profitieren sie
doch auch wiederum da ist es doch viel
besser wenn man
doch viel besser wenn man's zielgenauer
mit einmal ich will nur mal sagen ich
glaube kann die linke fährt auch mal ein
bisschen darüber nachdenken dass es
bürger geld da geht es ja nicht darum ob
jetzt zehn euro mehr oder weniger
sondern da geht und hundert
da sage noch mal auf den schaffen sie
nicht über nacht das bürgergeld wird
hartz 4 ersetzen und da geht's ich sage
es noch mal um den kulturwandel in den
jobcentern um eine unterstützung auf
augenhöhe wir wollen ja auch die ganze
förderlandschaft nochmal verbessern sehr
viel mehr auf weiterbildung setzen neue
instrumente wie begleitendes coaching
und aufsuchende sozialarbeit und
wirklich eine zielgenaue passgenaue
unterstützung
dieser form die machen sie nicht über
nacht die muss gründlich gemacht werden
die muss übrigens auch so gemacht werden
dass sie dann tatsächlich auch in den
jobcentern umgesetzt und erreicht er
nicht dass sie ein paar sätze nur ins
gesetz rasch ich würde trotzdem noch mal
ganz kurz nachfragen herr rosemann sind
tatsächlich einmalzahlung also auch was
jedes jedes kind soll 100 euro bezahlt
werden dann gibt es ja noch dieses
verbilligte pnv ticket für den
nahverkehr drei monate lang für neun
euro was passiert nach den
einmalzahlungen denn die energiepreise
auch die lebensmittelpreise werden
wahrscheinlich nicht so schnell runter
gehen wir werden das weiter beobachten
und wir werden gegebenenfalls auch
nochmal handeln also es muss ja nicht
das letzte entlastungspaket gewesen sein
ich sage aber auch die hohen
energiepreise im moment haben auch viel
mit spekulationen zu tun wir haben es ja
nicht mit einer realen rohstoffknappheit
zu tun sondern wir haben es ja mit
spekulation darauf zu tun das sehen sie
wenn sie zum beispiel den weltmarktpreis
für ein barrel öl neben der ja gesunken
ist aber in der zapfsäule ist es nicht
hat sich nicht bemerkbar gemacht und das
ist ja auch der grund dafür dass wir
auch gesagt kam verabredet haben gestern
dass wir auch wettbewerbsrechtliche
maßnahmen auch anwenden wollen um zu
verhindern dass mineralölkonzerne sich
die gewinne mit diesen spekulationen
einfach in die tasche stecken und auch
da werden wir ansetzen damit es eben
nicht bei diesen hohen energiepreisen
bleibt es macht ja keinen sinn dass wir
steuergeld das wir alle mühsam
wirtschaften müssen in die hand nehmen
damit es nachher diejenigen die mit
diesen preisen spekulieren am ende noch
einen größeren reibach machen
zum teil
noch eine frage bertels heil hat gestern
angekündigt dass die
erwerbsminderungsrente erhöhen wird drei
millionen rentnerinnen und rentner
sollen davon profitieren ab 2027
das müsste ihnen doch eigentlich
gefallen frau verschafft es ist
tatsächlich ein schritt in die richtige
richtung auf der anderen seite erleben
wir dass zum beispiel jetzt im haushalt
der sonderzuschuss für die rentenkasse
dieses jahr überhaupt nicht überwiesen
wird das heißt die rücklagen schmelzen
und es ist durchaus davon auszugehen
dass es zu rentenkürzungen kommt und das
kritisieren wir natürlich weil es da
nicht entsprechend die sicherheiten gibt
und man sieht auch dass jetzt wieder die
hand an den sozialstaat gelegt wird in
der bundesagentur für arbeit im übrigen
das gleiche die steuerzuschüsse werden
nicht gegeben sondern es wird lediglich
offensichtlich über einen kredit
finanziert und da ist die große sorge
dass jetzt wieder hand an den
sozialstaat gelegt wird wir werden dazu
gleich in der debatte noch einiges
erfahren ich möchte die wenigen minuten
immer noch haben rentenkürzungen
getrieben ich habe da noch einen solchen
zusammen sagt weil rennen also die
machen ja hier angst rentenkürzungen
drohnen und überhaupt nicht ganz im
gegenteil gestern kann mir die zahlen
raus wie die rentenerhöhung wenn sie
ausfallen wollen fünf prozent über fünf
prozent im westen und über sechs prozent
muss zum ersten juli ist das angekündigt
die rente ist tatsächlich ein großes
thema da müssen ein eigenes interview zu
führen wir werden da in der debatte noch
einiges zu hören ich würde ganz gerne
mit ihnen beiden weil es ein aktuelles
thema ist und viele menschen darauf
schauen die flüchtlinge die geflüchteten
die aus der ukraine zu uns nach
deutschland kommen da hat der
bundesarbeitsminister angekündigt nach
der akutphase die menschen haben erstmal
andere sorgen wir müssen erstmal
versorgt werden unterkommen und zur ruhe
kommen nach der akutphase will er es
ermöglichen das geflüchtete schnell in
den arbeitsmarkt integriert werden
können allerdings jetzt trifft sich
hubertus heil nächste woche mit
gewerkschaften und mit der wirtschaft
private unternehmer beispielsweise hier
in berlin waren schon wesentlich
schneller wir haben eine plattform eine
online-jobbörse eröffnet da sind schon
über 7.000 offene stellen 20.000
zugriffe
am tag muss man hinke politik da ein
bisschen hinterher nein es ist ja super
wenn die privatwirtschaft der initiative
das zeigt ja dass es einen bedarf an
arbeitskräften gibt und da geht's jetzt
da kommen viele auch gut ausgebildete
vor allem frauen aus der ukraine hierher
und es kann uns helfen bei der
bewältigung dieses mangels an
fachkräften aber auch an arbeitskräften
zum beispiel in der gastronomie und
deswegen ist das ist das wunderbare
müssen politik und wirtschaft hand in
hand arbeiten jede initiative es
hilfreich welche weichenstellungen frau
fesche sind jetzt wichtig um die
ukrainerinnen sind überwiegend frauen
hier gut in den arbeitsmarkt integrieren
zu können können sofern sie wissen nicht
wie lange die menschen bleiben wir
arbeiten möchten im wesentlichen zwei
aus meiner sicht heraus zum einen ist es
dringend nötig dass der arbeitsmarkt
reguliert wird weil gerade zum beispiel
der bereich gastronomie der angesprochen
worden ist wir sehr viele prekäre
beschäftigungsverhältnisse haben
minijobs überstunden und so weiter und
ich finde das nicht dass jetzt auf dem
rücken der menschen die aus der ukraine
hierher fliegen entsprechend die
arbeitsbedingungen weiter in diesem
zustand bleiben können und der zweite
punkt ist dass ich glaube es ist extrem
wichtig die infrastruktur zu schaffen
als wohnraum schulen kita um
entsprechend dann auch die kinder die
frauen in entsprechend versorgen zu
können und es wäre natürlich auch ein
wesentlicher schritt um die konjunktur
anzukurbeln und das würde insgesamt
helfen um auch den arbeitsmarkt zu
stabilisieren
dass ein blick auf das was uns die
nächsten wochen noch beschäftigen wird
jetzt schauen wir erstmal rein in die
haushaltsberatung ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich ist eine fesche für die linke
und martin rosemann für die spd dass ihr
heute morgen sich die zeit genommen
haben zu diesem interview